[Música]
bienvenidos a esta cita cultura el
registro de una noticia sin retorno para
el cine porque eso supone la decisión de
warner bros de estrenar al mismo tiempo
sus películas de 2021 en salas y en su
plataforma es biomax cabe decir que el
estudio fue el más usado de este año
pandémico cuando otro retrasaban filmes
se arriesgó al tercer intento y exhibió
tener pero su fiasco comercial más el
miedo a la poca afluencia le permiten
hoy justificar que estas 17 producciones
estén un mes en streaming y luego sigan
en salas en una medida que asegura
temporal para no acumular la precuela de
los soprano el remake de hyung o la
cuarta de matrix nadie sea más que
nosotros que las películas vuelvan a la
pantalla grande
sabemos que el contenido nuevo es el
sustento de la exhibición en salas pero
tenemos que equilibrar eso con la
realidad de que la mayoría de los cines
en estados unidos probablemente operará
con capacidad reducida en 2021
su argumento tienen dos pecados solo
piensa en los cines estadounidenses y no
contempla el daño a las salas globales
al cambiar el plazo de distribución del
cine al hogar y la descompensación en la
recaudación y eso ya es irreversible
por eso productores y cineastas
involucrados como venice benau o
christopher nolan han aupado en la
protesta con pronóstico de demandas este
último autor de tenet ya se había
erigido defensor de las salas empujando
a warner a sacar sus cintas pero ahora
se siente traicionado por lo que el
estudio no está contando y es que los
cines que queden abiertos serán un
complemento que en realidad busca
despegar a edición máx que en
comparación con sus rivales tienen menos
usuarios y que no informó a nadie de la
industria cuando muchos contratos se
basan en un porcentaje de la taquilla
quieren compensar a todas estas personas
si el modelo es engordar suscriptores va
de cómo tratas a hero cineastas ahora se
estrecha hacia las personas que han dado
mucho por estos proyectos merecían que
se les consultará y se les hablara sobre
lo que iba a pasar con su trabajo
la industria del cine está usando la
pandemia como excusa para sacar
beneficio a corto plazo y es muy
desafortunado así las cosas el estreno
de wonder woman 1984 cae perfecto es
ejemplo de la anti queja porque warner
si avisó a la directora patty jenkins y
a la actriz delgado de su estreno en
simultáneo y la retribuyó con 10
millones de dólares extra y porque más
allá de este modelo de exhibición esta
secuela es lo que necesitamos según la
crítica equilibra acción amor y humor
hans zimmer borda la banda sonora y
sobre todo ese es el blockbuster que da
esperanza aun cuando recrea unos 80
ignorantes del funesto año que se nos
venía
max
[Música]
frente a mi hija en la cena
woods materna
gestión
con este panorama que ha dejado a un
villano chileno como pedro pascal sin
bigote estimula que meng de david
fincher nos lleve a los inicios
cinéfilos si su cinta contó con un gran
talonario de netflix pero es uno de los
últimos autores de hollywood capaz de
tener un legado como éste tras
supervisar la serie manhunters ha
rescatado un guión de su padre jacques
que recrea la creación del clásico
citizen kane de orson welles y en
concreto el proceso del guionista herman
mankiewicz aquí un gary oldman que si
bien no se asemeja a él clava a este
genio errático y en cama y kamikaze
además de su cuerpo no pasó a los 55
años pero contribuyó a estas bambalinas
de hollywood y a esta historia no sólo
sobre un personaje sino sobre un
ambiente rupturista y único
[Música]
m
[Aplausos]
efe
finalmente la época mandaste a un grinch
o no la transición 2020 2021 se lleva
mejor con lucasfilm elevó poniendo patas
arriba el universo galáctico y
haciéndolos viajar en el tiempo por los
episodios de star wars a partir de una
rey que conocerá desde un joven look al
querido globo o baby yoga
y les toque
son chips mientras que el músico
británico jamie cullum es sin duda el
mariah carey navideño de nuestro tiempo
su de piano me and at christmas no sólo
es un álbum compuesto por el con
orquesta y big band que hace latir este
género sino su creación más exquisita
motivada por el encierro y una
colaboración anterior con roy williams
gocen de este mágico y espontáneo disco
y gracias infinitas por su compañía todo
este año
cuídense
[Música]
son mí